oh wow I literally don't give a [ __ ] I
don't think I've ever gotten a dick pic
not like not like a one I asked for like
I've had yeah yeah
but then have you have you ever felt the
need to also one no no that's the only
thing I can keep that to yourself I say
it's my guy friends I'm like I'm gonna
be real with you if a girl has ever I
mean never say never but again if we go
back to like majority and exception I
think majority of girls do not give a
[ __ ] and so if she's asking for a dick
pic she's probably just trying to
inflate your ego or act the way she
wants you to act yeah and the same with
threesomes though I know a lot of girls
who are like oh I've had threesomes and
oh wait let's add it oh wow what the
[ __ ] she looks good
okay
um with three I think more girls
actually like want to have threesomes
than admitted just for the record that
was not an explicit pick that was a very
no it's just in her face it was just it
was just a very busy
but obviously that's nothing but yeah
yeah I think uh it's rough because some
girls want free stuff statistically I
know I know the stats like most girls if
they're like surveyed on it like would
do a threesome but would they do it
because they want to or would they do it
because they know most women are
attracted to other women oh 100 I would
rather have a threesome yeah or 100 and
it's like really it really grinds my
gears especially on Tick Tock when girls
are like
oh girl crush or by Panic or I'm
straight I'm straight I'm sorry I'm like
you're not your queer you're attracted
to her it's actually internalized
homophobia to be like oh I haven't got
that part I'm uncomfortable being
attracted to a woman don't be you're
attracted to a woman it is what it is I
mean I think there's like levels there's
like being like like the nurse joint and
Pokemon when I was like six years I
think they're thinking they're
attractive and like wanting to sleep
with them or like yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I have a question why why is it
that if a guy is bi a God is less likely
to do
because if it goes by a guy's like
because I I why is there a double
standard thing okay I don't know I don't
know any guys who are buying the chat
you're welcome I don't know but when I
when I
when I slept with that that like Nikita
Dragon whatever
it ruined it for me what was that I I
don't know I like I can't tell you why I
just did he was just like I couldn't I
thought he was attractive before and
then after that
so if a guy takes one it's a feminine I
think this guy takes one eggplant in the
bum
it's a great it's a wrap for him why is
that a thing is there something you want
to tell us guys
oh my gosh in my industry it'll be so
much easier if I was so much easier no I
think it's I think it's like feminine
like that's more feminine we're like
is it yeah no no I'm saying this camera
which comedian said this right this this
comedian from Manchester but he was like
having sex with a
girls whatever they're soft it's nice
it's warm getting taken dick is hard
that's hard that makes you more that's
[ __ ] harder than that I don't know
why I can't explain it I I can't I don't
know okay on this same wavelength I feel
a bit weird about I feel a bit weird
about guys who are like insistent on
anal sex I'm a bit like
um and there's that quote in is it
forget is it Forgetting Sarah Marshall
where she's like if there's a playground
why you why you wanted to have fun why
you wanted to have fun in the store
I don't get it I get that oh I get that
I don't get it either
I I mean I'm agreement
I don't get it either my guy's like hey
can we do that and I'm like why would
you want that
that makes no sense to me it makes I
agreement
I get that I get that it's tight but I'm
like maybe you're a little bit gay like
maybe like no no
maybe like well a couple of my friends a
couple of my friends who have done
they're like oh it just feels better and
I'm like how I'm like you have to get
lube and everything so we're trying to
be just YouTube friendly I just don't
the other thing has natural yeah I don't
know I don't get it but I am I I am very
obviously because a lot of people in my
circles are of the you know LGBT but
it's pretty unanimous that women if
they're dating men they they if he's bi
always if he's had experience with guys
she's like no it just turns her off
completely yeah yeah I don't know why
that's something I tried to ask him for
you but they couldn't explain them I
can't explain it it just ruins it funny
with you I've slept with one guy that I
know aren't you pants yeah
and this is what I'm saying I slept with
one guy
um with the knowledge that he was
bisexual and I was like when he told me
I was a bit like I don't know why I'm a
bit like
about it but then being pansexual
I mean women are like okay with it like
but men [ __ ] love it man and I think
it's that whole idea of that's the
amount of men this past year who have
been like well you have a threesome with
me another girl and I'm like
I'll tell you now I'll have a threesome
with you another girl if you're both
like all about me but I would rather
have a threesome with like two women I
had a question for you do you like it if
it goes by
are you gonna do it yeah sure okay would
you be into it for a wife
and she was buying yeah yeah my first
girlfriend who honest my virginity she
was bi okay why oh I was just wondering
if it was different do you think I'll
say no I I thought you might I don't
know I'll be honest right I don't give a
[ __ ] what anyone says
as long as I'm the only dick in her life
she could do what she wants so she
called her like dating another girl yeah
you know what she that other girl
probably be doing me a favor in some
areas
like if she wants to go shopping and
what did you think I was talking about
oh my gosh that that shit's all mine
that [ __ ]
it's mine but again similar wavelength
is that guys yeah that's why I really
thought you meant they'd like be like oh
so she's gonna satisfy her butt so
that's it so got straight men
particularly if you see two girls
getting off or lesbians you're like love
that [ __ ] and I asked my friends I was
like what is it and they're like women
are great you've got double a good thing
is a great thing and I was like oh that
makes sense but then if you are straight
women or you see two gay men getting off
it's not the same it's not the same I
don't see too many gay men getting off
and I'm like what if they're really
really attractive it still wouldn't do
anything for me so it's a weird like
you know I'm like oh I don't and I think
that's a lot of even women sexually
objectify women that of course 80 of
consumer buying decisions are made by
women so so if women complain about
being sexualized in the media I'm like
ladies the media is for us it's
literally for us so it's like it's funny
because we complain about our own doing
because if they're marketing they're
marketing like like women like hot girls
too 100 I know a lot of I know a lot of
straight women and I'll say that I'm
like you're not straight you're
definitely queer but they'll watch porn
with their partners and be like Oh I'm
looking at the woman I'm not looking at
the man and I'm like yeah so you're
you're not yeah I I feel like a guy on
this podcast because like I I recruit
women for it and I want them to be hot
so I can like make money off of you guys
so like so I feel like I feel like a man
because I'm like oh she's hot let me let
me go talk to her you want to come on my
podcast that is pretty provision that
halo effect it's so real and I literally
I'm here for it if you can make you can
make more go for it I'll slide into
girls DMs like come on my podcast I'll
be honest if I was a hot girl like
giving dating advice
I'll be making so much more from that
yeah right now so much more